In the last few lessons, you've learned a lot of new information about
exponential and logarithmic functions. You've seen their graphs. You've learned
about properties that apply to them, and you've also learned how to evaluate
and manipulate them. In the coming videos, we're going to explore various
strategies to solve a variety of exponential and logarithmic equations. A few
lessons ago, we touched on an application problem where we considered the
amount of bacteria which remained alive after a patient was medicated. This
lesson is going to give you the tools you need to solve other application
problems as well. Maybe you're earning interest on a certain amount of money
that you've put in a savings account. Then we'd have an equation like this.
12,500 equals 10,000 times 1.03 to the t. Or perhaps you've just bought a loaf
of bread, but you're about to go on vacation. We could use an equation like
this to figure out how much mold would grow on the bread after a certain amount
of time. Or, what if you've just been through an earthquake, and you want to
figure out how intense the quake was? Well, you could use equations like these
two to talk about that. This one characterizes the earthquake that happened in
Japan in 2011. And this one talks about the worst earthquake that ever happened
to California, which was in 1857. These scenarios are all going to be super
interesting to look at, but I think we should wait a bit before we get to them.
For now though, let's stick with something pretty simple. You've been learning
with exponents a lot lately, so I think this equation is a good choice. We have
4 to the x equals 64. What does x equal then? Now, some of you might be able to
do this in your head or if that seems tricky you can try guessing and checking
using a calculator.